please go back home Millie Bobby Brown
and Sadie sing pretty gloriously reenact
a scene from frozen between takes on the
set of stranger things and we're going
to compare the remake to the original
regretfully go enjoy the Sun and open up
the game chicken and just stay away
you'll be safe from me
actually we're not what do you mean
we're not in the feeling you don't know
[Music]
I mean this is right up there with
Dustin and Susie's rendition of
neverending story
yeah let's let them do it and apparently
singing on set of stranger things is
pretty non-stop is there a lot of
singing on set oh my gosh yes every day
every second like with alcohol cut then
he'll just hair a little hung like the
game is gang always singing all the time
it's game Millie and Sadie it's like a
little bit like come on yeah but will we
see more of this dynamic duo in season 4
here's what Sadie wants to see for max I
don't know I mean I feel like this
season we got to see a lot of different
sides of her and I think where we leave
off in this season it's a very you know
interesting place that we can that they
can I'm excited to see what the
difference have planned they always
surprise me just when they think they're
gonna run out of ideas nope they've
always always got more in their back
pocket alright thanks for tuning in to
this musical video if you need me I'll
probably be singing frozen for the rest
of the day I'm watching that bizarre egg
video I can't stop watching it anyway if
you guys want more awesome stranger
things content we have so many great
exclusive seriously check them all out
and keep it locked to et until next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]